Tụi tưởng ba lăng đô năng tất cảnh báo,
lì mình đã tô đăng đối mặt với người cơ tăng sáng,
sông những sản nước mở bộ ngày càng xúc sáng.
Chẳng phát biểu gần đây ông chưa sáng bối đây sợ lớn nhất hiện nay không đến từ bên hoài.
Mà so far từ chính sử chiếc giải trong lì mình,
cảnh báo nên đưa ra trong bối cảnh Mỹ thông báo,
kế hoạch xuống khoảng 50% hỏi đứt.
Đồng thời xem xác giảm sử dựng sử dựa phân sự phạch cho ông,
theo hàng tiên vậters, quy định này làm giấy lâu ngại về căng kếc của Washington,
đối với anh đi khu vực.
Tổng thống đưa năng trăm cộng chỉ chính một dựa mình khác nghĩa tали và tế bằng nhà,
bây giờ ông hộ đầy đủ trí lâu của Mỹ trong xung đột đến quan tỷ văn.
Đặc biệt là vấn đề báo đảm anh điện hàng thải tại Vèn Thông Quốc,
ở chương lại một số lãnh thảo chua ông chưa đau có thủ tụng đất Friedrich Muzz,
bây giờ con ngày, bây kếc tế cận của Mỹ,
cho sản cần có một trí lợg gió sản hơn,
nhằm chẳng theo thân căng thẳng.
Rồi phân tinh nhận định những bắt đầu hiện nay có thể anh vượng tự sự gắn ghét và vai trọng của Nato,
cho một cạnh môi trường anh điên của tế đang biến đậu vức tạm.